hello uh my name is George stag I an
open- Source software engineer working
in the tiders team for posit um I'm the
lead developer of the web R project um
and today I I wanted to make a video to
talk about some of the changes in web
020 so if you don't know about webar
it's a version of our compiled for web
assembly uh so that it can run in a web
browser uh and other web assembly
environments such as node.js so this is
probably my favorite quick example of
what webar can do um this is a a code
block with some R code in it in this
case a a a linear model done in in base
R and if I hit the Run code button you
can see that that R code is is run and
the results shown to you on the screen
and and the important part about this is
that there's no R server uh running to
to execute that code that code is being
executed in the web browser directly on
this
machine this is live uh and interactive
so I can I can change it I can produce a
new R code and run it to get to get real
interactive live results um and that
also includes plotting I can I can I can
plot images there all directly in in the
web
browser so you can imagine um the the
the applications that that this opens
for for uses of r on the web um and the
ones I'm most interested in are things
like educational content so interactive
documents and presentations like this
one um and and educational doc uh
content uh including even things like
art
documentation um and and whereby having
those tactile interactive examples
directly in the web page and and I feel
really helps with with those use
cases um another thing we're beginning
to look at is the idea of
containerization of of an R application
and and sandboxing um and taking some R
application and and being able to run it
in its entirety on another machine
through through the idea of portability
and distribution of of web assembly
apps um I am also aware of one
application one person using web R um as
a way to access r on a tablet um in this
case they're they're running web R in a
web browser uh through their tablet on a
device that otherwise wouldn't be able
to access
R so uh as I say web R version 020 is
now available um the the top link shown
there is a a demo uh our reppel
application um reppel stands for read of
our print Loop um and it's it's another
name for the r console that that I'm
sure you're familiar with if you're a
JavaScript developer you can install web
R through npm or or you can uh run it
directly from CBN um and the
documentation to to integrate web into
your own programs is uh that URL there
um so let me talk about the updated uh
webar uh reel application uh but before
I do that um I'll just talk about the
changes since version uh 011 webon so um
we've updated the source version of R
from I think it was r410 to
430 uh we've changed the package name
from uh rwm we this the namespaced
package just to the web r package in in
mpm makes it a little easier to
install uh and we rebuilt the the demo
application using a more modern
framework we've we've migrated from
using jQuery to the react
framework we've expanded the
functionality of the in browser canvas
graphics and bitm Graphics
systems and we've made improvements to
accessibility and internationalization
in those Graphics systems and we're
supporting uh lots more R packages which
I'll talk about in a separate video
something else uh I'll talk about in a
separate video is uh changes to the
developer API um and if you want to read
more about that you can also read the
the news document inside the web R
repo so let me talk about the uh web R
reper app so it looks like
this and you can see if you saw the
previous version of the rep app it it
looks a bit different um as part of the
the redesign uh into uh into the react
framework um we've expanded the um the
the view so that there's now this uh
editor in the top left hand corner so I
can type R coding in here and you get
code suggestions
and syntax
highlighting uh all built into this this
uh code mirror uh code editor uh the
nice thing about this is that uh you can
also save the files directly to the
virtual file system that webar is
running in which takes you to this panel
here uh this is the uh the the uh file
system viewer built into web um it's
been expanded to have more controls at
the top to manage files and directories
on that virtual file system um and the
view itself the component U implementing
that that tree of directories has been
replaced um with a component um build a
react Library uh built designed to build
an accessible Tree View component so
that um users who um browse the web
through keyboard only for example are
are able to use this component uh
effectively the console is as it was in
the previous version uh the main
difference uh between the previous
version and this is that it has a
feature enabled that allows users to use
screen readers uh to read the input and
output of that console so if you're
doing some kind of analysis or in my
case just generating some random
numbers um the previous version of this
this component um that those those
results were not accessible to things
like screen readers um but here they are
so again users with access accessibility
issues who who need to use those tools
are able to use the r console in this
web app
effectively and then finally the last uh
panel is the plotting um panel so if
I run a command to produce some plots um
this is using a built-in Graphics device
into webon we're calling the the canvas
Graphics device it's it's drawing those
plots using a a fe a a web API know as
canvas graphics and you can you can move
through plot history and and save plots
into a bitmap file or clear them
directly from from this page final thing
I'll say about the editor is that um you
may have noticed earlier that as I type
um code suggestions are are produced
this is using a feature built into the
code mirror editor that um we've we've
hooked up to our's built-in code uh
completion engine um and that that that
means it's um it's context aware of of
the coda typing so if I type sample here
and then SI i z you can see it
suggesting the argument size to me and
and that's because the the code
completion generator knows that size is
is an argument to to to the sample
function which is really nice as as your
writing code to have those suggestions
given U intelligently like that um so
that's the rle application
um I'll move on now to talking about the
HTML canvas Graphics device which I I
briefly showed in the in the lower
portion of that
screen um so the canas graphics device
is built into um the web R application
and allows you to render Graphics in a
web browser we've made big improvements
uh since the last release uh by moving
from um the the the canvas API to to
this offscreen canvas API so here's a
video of producing a plot with 300,000
points from last version of webon and
you can see it's quite slow um the
reason for that is because each of those
points um is drawn by sending a message
from the worker thread where computation
happens in the web assembly environment
to the main thread where that that plot
is being drawn um so dispatching and
handling all of those messages for each
of those points separately creates a big
overhead and and that's what the main
cause of those performance issues were
in the latest version of webar it's much
improved it's it's it's an order of
magnitude faster and it's it's all
thanks to this this offscreen canvas API
uh what it does is it lets us draw the
image on the worker thread and then just
send a single message with the finished
image to the main thread to be
shown um using offscreen canvas has
enabled us to enable um much more
advanced text rendering features too we
can now take advantage of of the text
rendering provided by the the web
browser that web is running in and so
here's an example of some code again
running live in this slide uh showing
off some of those Advanced uh text
features um the uh biggest benefit of
this is probably that webon now supports
much better um International uh scripts
when when plotting so you can see
there's some Arabic text here some some
Hebrew and some Japanese uh and they're
all handled um automatically Now by by
the weball canvas Graphics
device that fall that font fallback that
enables this also allows you to use
emoji in your plot should you want to
um the nice thing about the canvas
Graphics devic is because we're relying
on the the web browser to plot um to
draw those Graphics we can actually use
Font files that are installed on the
users's machine we can use system fonts
so here for example I have family future
is the title but I can change that I can
say if I wanted
to um and this provides not only a
benefit to to internationalization for
all those alternative script uh but also
accessibility because there exist some
fonts that are designed to help users
with uh reading barriers such as
dyslexia to be able to comfortably read
text so there's a open dislexic is
dislexic is such a font you can see that
if I rerender that image that that font
is now being used for the the title and
the the X and Y labels so those users
who prefer to read text with that um
that font are now able to do so in web
should they
wish in addition to the canvas graphics
device um web also has updates to um
support the standard bitmap Graphics
devices built into uh built into R um so
if you're running in a browser that
doesn't have a if you're running an
environment that's not a web browser
such as a node server side or you're
running R code that isn't aware of the
canvas Graphics device you can now do so
with webar so here I have an example
that this is just loading web R into the
page and then there's uh some R plot en
code here U writing a PNG to to the
virtual file system and once that PNG
has been written to the virtual file
system with webar there are file system
apis that let you read that file into a
JavaScript variable and once you have
that that data in JavaScript you can do
what you need to do with it you can you
can offer it to the user as a download
uh you can display it in the page or or
if you're running server side you could
send that data over the
network the way this works um is that
we've compiled the chyo graphics library
and Pango text layout engine um to web
assembly as part of the web R build
process um and by compiling compiling
those libraries to web assembly and
linking them in uh we can enable those
Advanced text features that I already
talked about for the built-in Graphics
devices as well as the canvas Graphics
device the main difference between the
two is that for built-in um chyo
graphics with with PNG for example um
those fonts can't be read off the user
fast system and instead they must be
provided to Cairo through the through
the web virtual file system so web ships
with a minimal selection of Noto fonts
uh but if you do have other requirements
for different scripts or different font
type faces you can upload those fonts to
the virtual file system um and web has
been configured to to search that
directory home web user fonts for font
files and and use them so here's an
example um very similar to the previous
example I showed you uh the only
difference is this time it's creating a
PNG file instead of displaying it in a
browser um and you can see the results
are are very very similar and all those
text uh features that I talked about
things like uh lies in Arabic text and
the font fallback for for different
glyphs they're all supported including
uh the right to left text and um various
other
features um this works uh in this
example because I've uploaded some fonts
for those alternative Scripts to the
virtual file system in the in the
correct place and and web has
automatically then used them to produce
this
plot so um the last thing I want to talk
about in this video is uh something
we're calling the lazy virtual file
system so everything I've shown you so
far comes with a price um increased web
assembly download size data size you
know if you're bundling fonts they'll
have to be downloaded um but not every
user will want all of those features so
not every user will want use chyo
graphics and download those font files
so some some people will just want to do
some computation and and return some
numbers uh the same thing applies to
files built into R already so our ships
with lots of documentation and examples
and data sets um the they're not
necessarily needed for every user so it
would be nice if webar only downloaded
the data it actually needs to run your R
code and web 020 does just that it uses
a um an API provided by inscription for
their um for their their file system
environment that um allows the file
system to only download the files when
they're requested so here in this
example I'll just open the dev tools and
you'll see exactly what I mean so if I
refresh the page uh you can see the the
r files are downloaded to to run R and
its base packages but then if I run the
command PNG to use chyo Graphics to
build a bit Graphics uh image you can
see it's only at that point that those
Cairo libraries are downloaded to the
the the device um and the and the
similar thing if I plot something now
and I I draw some text you'll see that
the font files are only downloaded at
the point of actually producing that
plot so if I don't use chyo graphics and
and and produce a plot that requires
those fonts they won't be downloaded by
the user that's really nice because it
reduces the initial download size of web
by a lot um for the uh the the
application that I've been showing the
demo repel app um in the previous
version of web r with less features that
was 40 megabytes of download um in the
new version it's it's only 9.5 megabytes
and that's with the extra features um so
that's that's only 23% uh of of the
previous download size so that's a
really good Improvement for for the the
download size of of an initial web uh
loading uh of the engine into into a
page so that's everything I wanted to
talk about in this video um do try out
the the app um and and uh see run your
own R script um and if you're a
developer as I say you can install web R
from npm or CDN the documentation is is
shown there on on the screen at that URL
uh do go and read the documentation if
you if you want to try webar in your own
applications uh because there there are
some subtleties when it comes to um when
it comes to putting those those
applications on the web if you do create
something interesting with web um please
let me know my email address is is shown
on the screen and and and I'd love to
hear about it and um thank you very very
much for
listening